so eight on a friday morning happening
almost right now over a hundred
employers looking to hire for more than
for real more than ten thousand job
openings sharing that's a lot of jobs
and they're just waiting for the people
who are unemployed right now and need
work well the spring job fair is
happening at the las vegas convention
center and that's where we find mary
jane belliesa this morning and she's
going to tell us more on how you need to
be prepared dress for success get that
resume together good morning mary jane
tell us more this is great news for
locals
yeah absolutely sheri and nate good
morning to you the spring job fair gets
underway here in just a few hours i'm
actually joined this morning by malik
williams from workforce connections and
thank you so much for being with us this
morning tell me a little bit about what
job seekers can expect when they walk in
through those doors well thank you for
having me on this morning job seekers
should expect lots of opportunities when
you get here the doors to the convention
center will open at 7 30 a.m people can
come in right away start getting
themselves oriented getting checked in
there will be resume help and interest
career interest surveys on site are job
coaches and job developers will be here
to help people
if they need a little help tweaking that
resume or if they need someone to give
them a little advice about how to sit
down and have an interview we'll have
professional staff on site ready to do
that and when they come in there's
signage all over the place there are
these great directional signs you can
come in scan that qr code on the sign
and then it's going to pop up a map with
a list of all the employers over 100
employers who will be here today and
then give you a quick map to exactly
where to find those inside the hall all
you have to do is zoom in
find the employer that you want to talk
to and find your way around the hall
we'll have paper copies for those who
don't have the technology on them but
everything is geared towards the job
seekers today
lake thank you so much and again we are
talking about over a hundred employers
here today this event is free and open
to the public coming up in our next half
hour we'll talk to an employer about
what he is looking for in candidates
coming in reporting live mary jean
vallieza live local now